You know when you get that ambiguous
email from your boss
and you start to feel sweaty palms
and that empty, freaked out
sensation in your stomach?
Welcome back, anxiety.
Most of us think of anxiety
as a bad thing,
something to be avoided at all costs.
But what if it weren't?
What if you could take all of that energy
racing around your brain and your body
and transform it into something helpful?
[The Way We Work]
Global anxiety levels,
both the clinical kind and what I call
the everyday kind,
have increased tremendously
in recent years.
And many of us are noticing this at work.
We might think of anxiety as something
that we'd rather just leave
on the side of the road if we could.
But anxiety is an important tool
that arose during our evolution
that we use to avoid danger.
It's essential for our survival.
So how come we don't even feel
vaguely protected by it?
It's because the volume of our individual
and collective anxiety levels
has been turned way up too high,
and too much of even a potentially
good thing like anxiety is bad.
So I would like to share
two powerful, science-based tools
for turning down the volume on our anxiety
and helping us get anxiety back
to its helpful, protective state.
And both of these tools begin
by connecting with our bodies.
Tool number one is breath work.
It's just simple, deep breathing.
Slowly inhale and exhale.
This can be one of the most
immediate ways to calm anxiety,
because deep breath directly activates
the natural de-stressing part
of our nervous systems
called the parasympathetic nervous system.
I recommend a boxed breathing approach,
which is: inhale deeply on four counts,
hold at the top for four counts,
exhale deeply on four counts
and hold at the bottom for four counts.
You can even do this in the middle
of any anxiety-provoking conversation,
and no one will even know.
Lots of people,
from ancient monks to modern meditators,
have figured this tool out
and use it all the time.
Tool number two: moving your body.
This one also has immediate
positive effects on your mood state,
but for a different reason.
Every time you move your body,
you're releasing a whole bunch
of beneficial neurochemicals
in your brain.
These neurochemicals include dopamine,
serotonin, noradrenaline and endorphins,
mood and reward-boosting neurochemicals
that work to both increase
positive mood states
and decrease negative ones.
I like to say that every single
time you move your body,
it's like giving yourself a wonderful
bubble bath of neurochemicals
for your brain.
So when your boss's email comes in
and your heart starts to race,
what exactly can you do?
If you're in an office,
try taking a short walk around the block
or even to the supply closet
for some sticky notes.
If you're working from home,
put on two of your favorite songs
and dance around the living room
like no one is watching.
Studies have shown that all it takes
is ten minutes of walking
to get those mood-boosting effects.
But be creative
with your movement session.
Whether that's a quick session
of power vacuuming a la Mrs. Doubtfire
when you’re stressed about a deadline
or doing a set of jumping jacks
or getting off the elevator
one floor early
to do a power walk
up that last flight of stairs
before an important meeting.
All of these possibilities will all help
your anxiety levels come down.
In fact, I tested this effect
on my own NYU students.
First, I had them take
an anxiety assessment
before leading them in a movement session
that included movements
from kickbox and dance
and yoga and martial arts
together with positive
spoken affirmations.
Then I had them retake
that same anxiety assessment again.
What happened?
After our movement session,
their anxiety scores
had decreased to normal levels.
Now that's powerful, real-world example
that you can use in your life today.
So make sure to incorporate
these bursts of activity in your day,
and try one out next time
you're feeling stress.
It can really make your anxiety
feel less all-consuming.
Once you connect with your body
and turn the volume down on your anxiety,
two important things will happen.
First, when that email comes in,
you'll be in a better position to evaluate
what about it makes you anxious.
Is it that you've taken on too much
or that you feel insecure
about a particular skill set?
In other words,
you'll be able to use
this emotion, anxiety,
for exactly what it was evolved to do:
warn you about potential dangers
so you can become aware of them
and find ways to effectively
and creatively address them
in your everyday life.
Second, once you find the warning
signals in your anxiety,
you'll be able to communicate with others.
You might seek out advice
from a trusted colleague
when that difficult issue arises.
Or you might even have
a conversation with your boss
about how to prioritize projects.
Because you're no longer
in fight-or-flight mode,
asking for that support
won't feel nearly as threatening.
And one of the best gifts of approaching
your anxiety in this way
is that you will be able to notice
those telltale signs of anxiety
in everyone else around you,
especially those forms of anxiety
you're most familiar with.
And what will that do?
That will allow you to give that person
a smile or a kind word
to help them through that moment.
In other words,
your own form of anxiety can boost
your personal super power of empathy.
And I can't think of anything
we need in this world today
more than higher levels
of empathy for one another.
Your take-home in all of this?
If you breathe,
move and take note
of what your anxiety is signaling,
you'll feel more fulfilled,
more creative, more connected
and less stressed overall.
And that's my wish for every one of us.